for everyone and welcome to today's live
broadcast overcoming the challenges in
new european pharmacopoeia chapter four
wfi production presented by Tony
Harrison senior marketing manager at
Beckman Coulter I'm Suzy Valdez of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we're delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
Beckman Coulter before we begin I'd like
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation just click on the green
Q&A button located at the lower left of
your presentation window type your
questions into the box that appear on
the screen will answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation also notice that you're
viewing this presentation in a slide
window to enlarge that window just click
on the screen icon located on the lower
right if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window use that Q&A button
and let us know they're having a problem
one reminder that toward the end of the
presentation
audience members will have the
opportunity to answer a poll we really
encourage you to participate without
further ado I'd like to introduce our
presenter Tony Harrison mr. Harrison
held the convener ship of IFO working
group revising is zero one four six nine
eight section one and two for microbial
control in clean rooms and was the UK's
subject matter expert to the ISO working
group who issued the 2015 revised
version of the is zero one four six four
for section one and two documents for
cleanroom classification at the heart of
their septic manufacturing chapters of
both the European GMP and the usaac GMP
document Tony holds a Bachelor degree in
electrical and electronic engineering
and is employed by Beckman Coulter life
sciences as a senior marketing manager
experience in water system TIA
see conductivity and ozone analysis and
cleanroom environmental monitoring as
well as particle characterization Tony
has spent the last 15 years in applied
metrology for the pharmaceutical and
healthcare manufacturing industries
prior to that he worked for companies
providing process control automation
solutions for manufacturing industries
Tony was a joint editor on the is PE
guide to ozone sanitation of
pharmaceutical water systems and was
also the chief editor of the PHS best
practice guide for cleanroom monitoring
Tony is a well known international
speaker and has provided educational
seminars on toc liquid particle counting
ozone sanitation for water systems and
cleanroom monitoring in the UK France
Italy India Malaysia China USA
Scandinavia Ireland hungry Switzerland
Indonesia and many other countries
across the world I'd now like to welcome
mr. Harrison welcome thank you very much
for that introduction
I appreciate that hello everybody my
name is Tony Harrison today I'm going to
talk about the increasing importance of
monitoring for total organic carbon and
conductivity particularly in the likes
of the recent changes to the European
pharmacopoeia chapter for water for
injection so today's agenda I'll give
first of all I'll give a little bit of
history behind the changes to the
European chapter for watering water for
injection take a look at some of the
challenges in moving from production of
water for injection using us still to
using reverse osmosis such on the
increasing importance of total organic
carbon and conductivity monitoring in
these water systems there's a small
section on a toc measurement itself what
toc is and how it works and then I have
a section on best practice for
calibrating TOC and
conductivity analyzers and then there's
a section on support for water system
TOC Excursion root cause investigations
a section on a method for detecting
changes in water system organic
chemistry and they're now bringing it
all together in a conclusion at the end
so first of all let's take a look at
some of the history behind the changes
this recent change sorry to the European
pharmacopoeia
although much work has been done over
the last decade to harmonize the farm it
appears across the world the European
pharmacopoeia chapter on water injection
stood out because it specifically called
for the use of a still for the
manufacturer of water for injection
other farmers appears merely listed the
key quality parameters of water for
injection which are toc conductivity
microbial colony forming units and then
toxin levels however we pressure through
use carbon footprints and reduce
manufacturing overheads representatives
from the United States Pharmacopeia the
European pharmacopoeia and the Japanese
pharmacopoeia came together to survey
the pharmaceutical industry regarding
the quality of water manufactured by
reverse osmosis and in particular the
level of control these water treatment
plants had over microbial colony forming
units during the period from 2004 to
2010 the JP USP an EP gathered surveys
on water for injection from reverse
osmosis from across the world
and the results were surprisingly good
with many studies showing an excellent
water quality batching water for
injection standards and with very good
levels of microbial colony forming unit
control in 2011 an expert workshop was
formed with representation from the
pharmaceutical manufacturing industry to
consider changing the European
factor on water injection to allow use
of reverse osmosis as long as the water
produced that way met the korky quality
attributes old water for injection and
showed high levels of control and
finally in 2016 the new chapter for
water injection in the European
pharmacopoeia was adopted allowing for
the first time the use of reverse
osmosis for the production of water for
injection
however certain challenges exists for
those who wishing to change their water
production process from a still over to
reverse osmosis there are three main
drivers for the industry to move from
stills to reverse osmosis manufacturers
are of course under pressure to meet the
reduction in carbon footprint and energy
consumption set in the climate change
agreements and at the same time the loss
of patent protection an increasing
global competition means that companies
need to reduce their operating overheads
in order to remain competitive on a
global scale and finally many have
recognized that heat sterilization of
water systems only controls the
microbial levels and biofilm build-up
and that alternative treatments such as
ozone cannot actually offer improved
microbial sanitization and biofilm
control if they're used correctly
producing
water injection using a still is a very
energy consuming process they're still
itself using vast amounts of energy to
heat the purified water until it turns
into steam the steam is then condense to
form water for injection as the water
injection is made hot it's transferred
into the storage vessel and distribution
system hot as well to discourage
microbial build-up in the storage tank
and the distribution look they're both
kept hot
although the storage vessels varying
size commonly in a large manufacturing
facility they contain thousands of
liters of water and this must be heated
and maintained temperatures higher than
65 degrees centigrade to prevent
microbial excursions points of use that
require cool or cold water either for
the process reasons or for the safety of
the personnel they have to have the
water cooled using heat exchanges which
again consume energy and as the points
of use or effectively small loops in
themselves any waters not used
circulates back into the distribution
loop and this has to be reheated back up
to above 65 degrees centigrade before it
enters the loop periodically the water
in the storage tank and distribution
loop has to be heated up to temperatures
higher than 80 degrees centigrade to
hold back the formation of bias on
inside the pipe work each though
stationed abroad system tends to control
the proliferation of biofilm and
microbial contamination microbes living
in a heat sanitized water system are
generally unable to replicate to form a
colony and hence the term commonly heard
these days about viable but non
culturable ozone sanitization however
actively oxidizes the organic material
in the water
including the microbes themselves and
removes life and its source of
nourishment from the water system if
used correctly and leading to true
sanitization of the water system biofilm
can build in heats their eyes systems
and though it's kept under control by
frequent heat sterilization its presence
can form a challenge when switching
switching from an established heat
sterilized system over to ambient water
manufacturing using reverse osmosis so
let's take a brief look at the
alternative system suppose for water
injection production using the reverse
osmosis and ozone under normal
conditions the osmotic pressure across a
water permeable membrane causes the
water to pass through the membrane to
the side with the highest concentration
of salts reverse osmosis as the name
suggests reverses the direction of the
water flow by pressurizing the incoming
water side of the membrane so that clean
water is pushed through the membrane
leaving the contamination that was
present on the water behind water made
through the reverse osmosis process is
manufactured at ambient temperature and
does not require high energy input to
heat it a study done by a working group
from the pharmaceutical industry and
water system suppliers under the
auspices of the International Society to
a pharmaceutical engineering aspe
results in the publication in 2012 of
the is PE guide on ozone sanitization of
pharmaceutical water systems
which recommends the advantages of ozone
sanitization and lays down best
practices typically ozone is generated
by electrolysis of the water itself in
the loop and injected into the return
leg of the water loop because the ozone
is generated from the water itself
there's no risk of contaminating the
water systems levels of ozone are
maintained at all times in the storage
tank so as the water is circulated
through the tank it is sanitized excuse
me as the ozone is considered an added
substance it must be removed before the
water is used when this is achieved -
using an ultraviolet light which is an
ozone destruct system in the water loop
itself and as the water leaves the
storage tank it's destroyed using the UV
light ozone breaks down very rapidly and
the presence of UV light and is
prevented from entering the water loop
periodically when the water system is
not being used by production UV destruct
lights turned off allowing ozonated
water to circulate throughout the entire
loop the ozone destroys both microbial
contamination and any biofilm that's
been built up inside the pipe work if a
water injection system is quite old
there's a very real possibility of
biofilm buildup microbes can live in the
biofilm in a novia trophic state without
being detected the Common Era when
retrofitting an ozone sanitized reverse
osmosis plant to such a wart system is
not allowing for a suitable time period
to allow the ward system to come back
and control when first applied the ozone
will start to break down the surface of
the biofilm oxidizing the organic
materials to form carbon dioxide and
this carbon dioxide dissolves in the
water and elevates the conductivity so
we're going to have spikes of TOC and
elevated conductivity
secondly as the biofilm is broken down
organic material will slough off the
inside of the pipe and elevated TOC
levels in the water with elevated levels
of organic material in the water and a
return to ambient temperatures microbes
present in the biofilm may start to
proliferate causing elevated microbial
count in the water until the ozone does
its job and destroys the microbes to
eventually as the ozone destroys all the
biofilm and the TOC in the water the
loop will return back to normal control
and can use for normal operation so
let's take a look at the importance or
increasing importance of TOC in these
new reverse osmosis water for injection
systems
in September of 2004 the FDA issued
their process analytical technology
guidance encouraging the pharmaceutical
industry to change their bias on final
product testing and employ more online
process monitoring analyzers an attempt
to get a better process understanding
and better process control leading to
improved right first time results online
monitoring particularly for TOC and
conductivity have taken on an even
greater significance since the European
pharmacopoeia adopted its reverse its
revised monograph on water for injection
in March of 2016 allowing for the first
time the generation of water injection
from reverse osmosis the working group
responsible for advising the European
Directorate on their new water injection
monographs
gave a warning that reverse osmosis may
not be as robust as stills and they
encourage a focus on online TOC and
conductivity monitoring as early warning
of potential RO reverse osmosis
integrity breaches so let's take a look
total organic carbon just what it is and
how its measured the FDA mandate for
critical water quality attributes
monitoring for inorganic contaminants
using conductivity monitoring for TOC
monitoring friendo toxins and microbial
colony forming units as I mentioned
earlier the FDA encourage online process
monitoring for quality control in their
process analytical technologies or p80
initiative third the same tying
expectations for the amount of quality
information is increasing and in many
cases the responsibility for collecting
this data is passing to relatively
unskilled production staff a recent
report indicated that 79% of the FDA's
483 warning letters issued in 2016 to
the pharmaceutical industry they cite
data integrity as an issue
poor data integrity may lead the FDA to
call for a product recall total organic
carbon is a nonspecific test ie the
results of TOC analysis can tell you the
levels organic carbon in the water but
it cannot tell you exactly what those
organic substances are TOC is a
measurement of the mass of carbon atoms
present in organic material in the water
reporting TOC in units of mass per liter
of water
ie micrograms per liter or more
frequently expressed as parts per
billion the carbon atoms are released
from the organic molecule by breaking
the molecule down throughout the process
of oxidation the carbon forms into
carbon dioxide which in turn dissolves
into the water to elevate the waters
conductivity before the TOC is measured
the TOC analyzer must first measure the
amount of carbon dioxide in dissolved
oil in the water already and this is
called total inorganic carbon then the
organics present in the water are
oxidized to release the carbon they
contain and total carbon is measured by
subtracting total inorganic carbon from
total carbon the levels of total organic
carbon in the water can be ascertained
in the European pharmacopoeia chapter on
TOC it emphasizes the importance of
ensuring the complete oxidation of the
organic molecules to ensure that all
organic carbon is released and measured
accurately most TOC analyzers use to
monitor pharmaceutical grade water use
ultraviolet light to oxidize the organic
materials releasing the carbon atoms in
the form of carbon dioxide carbon
dioxide dissolves into the water
elevating the conductivity and it's this
changing conductivity is measured by the
TOC analyzer and used to calculate the
amount of organic carbon
Pleasant in the water the problem is
that as complex long-chain molecules are
broken down during the oxidation process
they may form organic acids which
contribute more strongly to the water
conductivity than the final carbon
dioxide does if the TOC analyzer does
not complete the oxidation of the
organic molecule one of two things may
happen either the carbon remains bound
up in the organic and cannot be measured
so the TOC is actually underreported or
the TOC analyzer takes a conductivity
measurement before complete oxidation
when the organic acid is present and
over reports the amount of TOC in the
water either way assuring complete
oxidation is the only way to measure TOC
accurately as these TOC allies are in
fact used conductivity to measure the
the TOC it's attractive to use them to
measure both TOC and conductivity
however the pharmacopoeia insist on two
calibration steps or for conductivity
analyzers the first one is to make sure
you can measure the the cell constant of
the conductivity analyzer using a
certified traceable solution and the
second one is to check the accuracy of
the air conductivity meter electronics
using an external certified resistor so
if TOC analyzers and conductivity I have
analyzed are to provide accurate
indication of the health of the water
system they must be calibrated correctly
so in this section we'll take a look
best practice for calibration of these
analyzers there are two types of
calibration the eye the international
standards organization ISO defines
calibration as a validation of an
instrument against the known certified
certified
calibration standard if the measurement
error is not acceptable when compared to
these standards then a calibration
adjustment must be undertaken to adjust
the instrument calibration slope to
bring this performance within acceptable
tolerances when calibrating an
instrument best practice dictates that
the current performance of the
instrument to be checked before any
adjustments is made this as found
calibration confirms that the instrument
has been working within except for
tolerances in the period of use then the
instrument calibration should be
fine-tuned to adjust it so that it reads
as close to the certified standard
values as possible to avoid long term
calibration drift having made this
adjustment calibration should be checked
once more validated against certified
standards to make sure the adjustment as
less the instrument working accurately
now there are 21 CFR part 11 issues with
the typical instrument calibration and
system suitability testing with many
manual SOP steps to be followed in the
typical water monitoring process they
are used for certified standards used in
the calibration process of manually
typed into the toc analyzer both
calibration and system suitability
inviting human error and miss typing
pass/fail reports has to be manually
calculated and finally the electronic
record is created by folks topping the
manual calculations and manually typing
the results into the system and all of
these steps can be prone to human error
leading to 21 CFR part 11 integrity
issues now if we're to rely on the TOC
analyzers to provide accurate
information support batch release data
and there are some significant issues to
consider
as I discussed earlier
pharmaceutical-grade tears the analyzers
rely on ultraviolet light to oxidize the
organic molecule to release the carbon
dioxide for TOC analysis total carbon -
total inorganic inorganic carbon equals
total organic carbon however as the UV
lamp inside the TOC analyzer ages the
intensity of UV light output reduces and
this can result in poor TOC analysis and
certainly in tears the analyzers with
continuous flow and fixed oxide they
oxidization time should the UV lamp fail
completely in the TOC an analyzer and it
will be unable to oxidize the organic
molecule and free the carbon atoms so we
will be unable to measure TOC at all in
a modern water treatment system with low
TOC levels between 5 and 10 parts per
billion a UV light failure may go
undetected and the user runs the risk of
releasing products onto the market
without accurate TOC analysis results
especially as an out of specification
TOC excursion would go undetected during
the time period before the UV lamp is
replaced naturally any TOC or
conductivity excursion would lead to a
root cause investigation the problem is
that TOC excursions can often be short
transient events detected by the TOC
analyzer for disappearing by the time
the team comes to take the water samples
root cause in vista investigation as
stated earlier one part per billion
carbon is equivalent to one microgram
per liter of carbon in a liter of water
sorry so let's take a look look at a
typical situation in this modern water
injection system on the street year the
TOC levels are commonly recorded around
26 parts per billion
a Slugger toc is fed into the water
system by accident from one of the
points of use causing excursions of 750
parts per billion on all the other
points of use equivalent to 7 750
micrograms per litre of water this it
detected and reported by the online TOC
analyzer the 750 micrograms per liter of
carbon now enters the water injection
StorageTek which in our example contains
a thousand liters of water for injection
the 750 milligrams of carbon is now
diluted in that thousand litres of water
and becomes just a point seventy five
micrograms per liter or 0.75 parts per
billion
this diluted carbon is very easily
destroyed by the you can grant commonly
used for microbial control and water
injection systems as the water passes
back out from the storage tank into the
distribution loop now TOC levels in the
loop return to their safe flow TOC value
but it's too late because during the
excursion the levels of TOC at the
points of use was outside the
pharmacopoeia limits and any batch has
been manufactured at that time cannot be
released into the market what makes the
situation worse is there's no way to
carry out root-cause investigation
analysis to find the likely sources of
the TOC excursion as all the evidence
has been defectively destroyed and
diluted in the water storage tank and
using the UV lamp so there's no way to
put preventative action in place to stop
the recurrence of the excursion again at
a later date thus compromising future
batches of products as well so we've
learned that the European pharmacopoeia
has paved the way for companies to
reduce their carbon footprint reducing
their NGO heads and being a better place
to compete globally by allowing water
injection generation by reverse osmosis
however we've also seen that the expert
committee advising the European
pharmacopoeia warned that River
osmosis may not be as robust and they
recommended increased increased focus on
TOC and conductivity analysis as a first
indicator that the reverse osmosis
integrity may be becoming compromised so
now let's take a look what else may help
warn us about possible compromises in
our water for injection generation
system monitoring the TOC level itself
may give us sufficient information that
got one other indicator that things may
be going wrong is a change to the type
of organum organic contaminants present
in the water
TOC analyzers that can report a change
in the oxidation profile of the organic
in the water may actually help us spot
when things are starting to go wrong in
time for us to take action before an
excursion appears an elevation in TOC
levels combined with a change in the
oxidation profile of the organic very
well hint that not only the TOC levels
creeping up but the type of organic
getting into the water system has
changed as well leading us to carry out
more in-depth water grab sample analysis
to check what might be going wrong so
we've learned that TOC and conductivity
analyzers can be strong allies to help
us keep our water systems under control
we've learned how calibration is
important and how complete oxidation is
recommended but but in the European
pharmacopoeia for complete and accurate
TOC analysis so let's take a look now as
to how the p80 700 TOC n conductivity
analyzer can help support you through
the challenges are moving to water
injection production moving from reverse
reusing our reverse osmosis sorry in the
p80 721 CFR part 11 issues are removed
all calibration and system suitability
SOPs are built in and automated there's
no manual data entry and no manual
patience calibration and system
suitability standards certified values
are contained in an RFID type in the
base of the standards bottle this data
is read by the P 8700 when the standards
are placed into the calibration Bay thus
eliminating manual entry and eliminating
manual data entry at the same time the P
8700 checks that the standards are still
in dates and now actually inserted in
the correct order in the calibration Bay
the P 8700 is unique in that it has two
auto switch in main and stand by UV
lapse it monitors the UV lamp light
output and should the main UV lamp fail
it automatically switches the standby
lamp on and sets an alarm to warn the
user that UV lamp requires changing at
the next service not only that this
analyzer compliant 40 OC requirements
but it can also be fully calibrated to
the usb requirements as a conductivity
meter to the cell constant can be
checked using a verified certified
conductivity solution and the meter
accuracy can be verified against a
resistor of known certified value the
itlp 8,700 ensures complete oxidation
every time initially the conductivity of
the water sample is measured to
establish the quantity of baseline total
inorganic carbon then the ultraviolet
light is turned on the p80 700 monitors
the changing conductivity in in the as
the organic molecules are oxidized to
carbon dioxide when there's no further
change in the conductivity the analyzer
measures the new conductivity and
compares it with the baseline total
inorganic carbon conductivity the
difference in conductivity is directly
proportional to the amount of organic
material trapped in the water sample as
mentioned earlier in the presentation
TOC excursions can frequently very short
transient events so the p80 700 supports
root cause investigation into these TOC
excursions by capturing a sample of the
TOC excursion into an empty excursion
bottle which is preloaded in the
calibration Bay this can then be taken
to the QC lab the root cause
investigation to identify the possible
sources of the contamination and
supporting corrective action and
preventative action kappa so to
summarize the EP 8,700 toc and
conductivity analyzer from Betancourt is
designed to be robust with all necessary
SOPs built-in and automated there's no
manual data entry of all calculations
and uptime is maximized by having
auto-switching main and stand my new he
laps there's a 12-month service interval
and calibration interval and it needs no
reagents it is designed to be fully
compliant for both toc and conductivity
and it does it ensures complete
oxidation to get accurate TOC results
every time it captures a sample of any
excursions so I can support root cause
investigations and it uses Microsoft's
Active Directory controls for username
and password given complete compliance
to 21 CFR part 11
my talk today I believe you should have
just received a poll inviting you to
download my white paper on this topic
which has more information as I say that
concludes my presentation today so thank
you very much for listening if there are
any questions then I'd be happy to take
them thank you so much Tony for your
presentation and for your important
research we will now start the live Q&A
portion of this webinar if you have any
questions audience members that you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of your presentation window type
those questions into the box that appear
on the screen and click the send button
well answer as many as we have time for
so let's get started we have a great
audience today and some wonderful
questions already coming in our first
question tony is if TLC excursions can
be transient events how can a proper
root cause investigation be carried out
you
audience members I think he might have
his presentation right there he is
there's no story I may repeat the
question no that's great sorry class and
he was on mute yes so yeah you're quite
right to use the events they are some
very short-lived transient events so and
of course the get to root cause it's
important to capture a sample of that
water whilst the TOC excursion is
happening in order to establish where
the TOC spike may have come from and
that's why the P 8700 from Betancourt
catches a sample of that water whilst
the TOC event is actually happening
thank you for that our next question is
if the pharmacopoeias mandate the system
suitability test as a requirement for
toc analyzers why is it separate
calibration procedure required yeah it's
good question and often system
suitability is confuses people
in fact system suitability is not a
calibration it merely establishes that
the TOC analyzer is capable of oxidizing
they're relatively difficult to oxidize
substance benzoquinone as well as it can
oxidize the more easily oxidized sucrose
a calibration adjustments however adjust
the analyzer measurements loads give the
best results when compared to certified
TOC standards and a three point
calibration could also establish the
measure that the measurement slope is
linear and the p80 700 automates both
system suitability and calibration and
calculates the pass/fail results and the
linearity with the analyzers
measurements slope great thank you and I
want to thank our audience members for
their questions we do have one more
coming in and we encourage others to
continue to write our next question is
in a TOC analyzer using UV light to
oxidize the TOC for analysis what
happens if the UV light starts to fade
sure it's while uv-light is critical to
the analysis and in fact in most TOC
analyzers UV light output is not
monitored directly so when a UV light
starts to age and its output starts to
drop off and the TOC analyzer will no
longer be oxidizing correctly and that
and the analyzer will under report and
for this reason the p80 700 directly
monitors the UV lamp output and
automatically switches to a standby UV
lamp should the main lamp begin to sail
thank you and thank you audience members
for your participation Tony did you want
to close with any remarks to the
audience to kind of wrap this
presentation up for them oh actually one
more question just came in do you want
me to go ahead and answer ask you that
question yes please hmm okay we have
Kenneth toc readings be used to trend
endotoxin levels so that would be nice
wouldn't it what a nice idea sadly no
because it's a it's not a specific test
TOC analysis is just an indication of
how much organic carbon there is there
it can't actually tell you whether it's
a an Ender toxin or not however as I've
mentioned if you see a change to the TOC
levels combined with a change of the
oxidation profile which the p80 700 will
report to you or tell you if there's
been a change in the oxidation profile
that's a good indication there's a
change to the organic chemistry in the
water system and certainly an indication
that more in-depth investigation could
be required wonderful thank you so much
Tony did you want to wrap up your
presentation with any closing remarks
for our audience members today just to
say thank you everybody for listening
today and thank you for the questions
it's been a good interactive session
Thank You Tanya thank you for your
important research at all
I'd like to thank laborat and our
sponsor Beckman Coulter for making
today's educational webcast possible
before I go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through April 2018
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when the webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now and thanks for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
bye bye okay